foreign
[Applause]
Jennifer Aniston reuniting with a
friend's guest star what the actress
Maine Whitman who in 2023 you know from
TV shows like good girls you know can't
you just have my back on like one thing
ever but rewind to 1996 eight-year-old
maze playing a Girl Scout in season
three
how many more boxes would you have to
sell in order to win
the girl who won last year sold
475. yeah so far I've sold 75.
and 26 years later
foreign you broke a little girl's leg
Jen and may catch up backstage at Live
with Kelly and Ryan
just wanted to say hi because
absolutely
thank you and it's always stayed with me
May drops this moment on the gram
remembering how Jen made her feel
welcomed and loved on the set you guys
always stayed with me so nice to see you
you're amazing this comes two years
after Jennifer had another friend's
reunion we had amazing guests and then I
walked on the set and I had no idea that
seeing everything look exactly the same
and incredible friends that
into a lot I I still was just like
generally are you crying she's like yeah
once her Gates opened then it was I
couldn't shut it off this will be the
last time that we're ever asked about
the show as a group that we will do this
like we're not going to do this again in
15 more years yeah fans won't see the
big six together again but with 10
seasons and over 200 episodes
seems there will be plenty of reunions
like these to get emotional over thank
you it's
so nice to see you you're amazing
[Music]